Rebecca why did you feel the need to go
in there and protest today
well I'm here with Greenpeace and
normally I come to the Conservative
Party Conference every year to meet with
MPS to Lobby to do my job as head of the
political team but this year we felt
like we really needed to take a
different approach and take a direct
message to the prime minister to say who
voted for this who voted for what Liz
truss and her cabinet are trying to roll
out across the country nobody voted for
fracking nobody voted to trash nature
nobody voted to cut benefits nobody
voted to slash workers rights yet
somehow Liz trust seems to think that
that's okay and she's seems to be
hell-bent on rolling this stuff out
across the economy and we needed to come
in there and send a message on behalf of
the public that she does not have the
public mandate to do this but there will
be members of the public who will look
at this and say actually I can't afford
to put my heating on I'm really really
worried about the cost of my mortgage
and actually environmental concerns and
the possibility of fracking happening in
the UK are pretty low down some people's
agendas
well actually looking at public polling
that is absolutely not the case all of
the recent opinion polls show people are
very very concerned about the climate
and nature emergency and indeed the
government's own research has shown that
protecting the environment and economic
growth go hand in hand it is completely
false that the government should suggest
that slashing regulations and trashing
nature somehow gets in the way of growth
you can't have a growing economy if our
rivers are polluted with sewage and if
our national Landscapes are completely
trashed under concrete and bulldozers
these two things need to go hand in hand
the government actually has been elected
on a Manifesto to tackle inequality to
stop the benefits freeze to support
people struggling and actually the
government's latest policies will not be
doing that and we needed to take a
message into the conference center today
directly to Liz truss and say nobody
voted for this and she needs to be held
to account but you are in the conference
center as you said Greenpeace is
regularly attend these events you know
you've got your stall there presumably
you have full access to all of these
ministers to the Prime Minister herself
this is just publicity stunt isn't it
it's not really about sending a message
to to the people who are inside the tent
because you're inside the tent with them
you've got your own flipping stall
absolutely and what's been very
interesting this year is first of all
how few conservative MPS are even at
this event because so many of them
disagree with the policies that Liz
truss and her cabinet are trying to roll
out across this country they are not in
line with the manifesto that the
conservatives themselves were elected on
in 2019 but you know actually I think
what's been made clear is that Liz truss
is not prepared to listen and we are
hearing them her and her Chancellor
coming out saying we listened we're
going to roll back on the 45p tax cut
but in fact many of the other policies
that the government is still thinking of
rolling out in terms of other tax cuts
for the super rich deregulation to trash
nature fracking they are not in line
with what the public wants they're not
in line with what conservative voters
actually voted for in 2019 this
government is not listening and that
calls for taking a different approach to
the conservative conference this year
and giving a direct message to the Prime
Minister it didn't go down one of the
hall though it certainly didn't seem
that those in the hall were particularly
on your side
I think that's what you would expect for
being right inside a conference Hall
there but I know for sure that many many
conservative voters are really dismayed
to see many of the policies that are
being rolled out and in fact over the
last three days that we've been at this
conference we've had quite a number of
conversations with conservative members
who have said that they're really
unhappy with the way in which Liz Tross
is pursuing her policies to roll out
fracking to do tax cuts for the super
rich to not follow through on many of
the promises to tackle inequality in
this country so I think actually the
overall mood both within the
conservative party but with the general
public is of great concern about the
agenda that Liz truss is trying to roll
out across the country